all right we're gonna have some sick
winds later today already got some sick
clouds out there skies look beautiful
don't they looks like maybe he's already
been painting the sky for us gorgeous
with that early color off on the horizon
we're still about 20 minutes away from
that sun coming up close maybe not quite
59 is the temperature thanks to the
clouds keeping things kind of mild
Sunrise 703 takes a couple extra minutes
with the mountains 5 45 is the sunset
and both of those will be an hour
earlier come Sunday as we change our
clocks the air is still pretty dry
temperatures outside the valley mostly
in the 50s we've got some low 60s in
front mid 60's in Sandy Valley low 60s
in Laughlin we're already getting some
winds Northwest of the valley out of the
South those Southwest winds are going to
be increasing today I'll show you the
areas with wind advisories Thursday we
get the core of this low pressure with
much cooler changes a chance of Valley
rain and Mountain snow and again we do
fall back to Standard time this weekend
here's the low pressure it's got a lot
of cold air pouring in behind it ahead
of the cold front is where we get the
Southwest winds today so you can see the
clouds will start to thin out later
today the afternoon should be mostly
sunny lots of wind advisories winter
storm advisories and warnings those wind
advisories for Southern Nevada start at
noon go all the way until nine o'clock
but for our local mountains they last
until 6 a.m look for 20 30 plus mile an
hour winds for the valley and those
warmer winds are going to push our
temperatures near 80 degrees today but
we'll start cooling off tomorrow partly
sunny skies with mid 60's chance of rain
Wednesday night into Thursday and much
cooler highs in the mid 50s morning lows
in the 30s and 40s Friday morning that's
where you're going to need warm jackets
and sweaters and we'll inch our way back
to near 70 degrees finally by Sunday